welcome back to pj chain design today we
are going to talk about how to use the
sweet command to make this transition
look nice
on this heart pendant are you ready
let's get started
i'm coming to the top view and to start
drawing this heart shape
um one thing i like to do is always
make sure that two of the line that i'm
drawing it's actually a little bit
overlapping
let me show you what that is is i will
have this one instead of starting from
this point
i'm gonna coming over to the side and
then you can draw any of the shape that
you
want i basically want one big and one
small
something like that and you can also
turn on the control point
to drag those points to make sure that
they are the shape that you like
all right and if the line doesn't look
smooth to you you can use the smooth
command
and that will help you to make the line
a little bit smoother
uh you can you know move in the bar here
and click ok
so that line will look smoother or you
can rebuild them
whichever is gonna work for you okay so
i'm going to stop
tweaking here and this line i'm going to
use
a smooth command again and to make them
a little bit smoother and nicer or
something like that
and click okay here all right so this is
my heart there
now we are going to use a sweep command
but i need to have some control point
there
so i'm going to coming into the top view
i'm going to draw a square
and starting from this point i'm going
to draw
roughly about this size i mean you can
change the size for whatever you want if
you
especially want to setting the stone you
probably want to make sure that
uh the size can fitting into your stone
and we are going to making a copy
i'm gonna making one to the bottom right
here and
one to the side roughly in the middle
there
to have a better sweep we need to have
this
almost 90 degree toward to the
rail that we are going to sweep and we
are going to do the same thing
over here and we we're gonna do the same
thing over here
this is actually 90 degree okay all
right so we are going to do
a test right there let's go ahead to
use the sweep one rail and we are going
to record
history and i'm going to click on here
click here here and here
make sure that they are aligned into the
same place
and this 2 is actually the same and this
one
is not facing the same direction so i
need to flick
uh flip that one and
let's click okay and we'll get something
really really
uh standard look like here
all right because we recorded history
now we can take a look on this one and
say okay i actually wanted to twist
inside a little bit so then you will
have a nice twist
i might want to have this one scale it
down a little bit there
and if you need to twist a little bit
more we can do that with the gumball
by keep twisting it and this curve i may
want to have it smaller as well
okay so if you feel like this is what
you want that's great
we're going to stop there and if you
feel like you might want to have it get
smaller over there and then coming up
to this twist so you might want to add
in one section over there
and i'm looking at the top view i want
to make sure that
it's sweep nice so i'm going to tilt it
this one a little bit
and maybe twist it a little bit more so
then you have that nice twist and i can
set the stone over there if you want to
by the way if you are enjoying my trick
and tips so far you may want to consider
joining the membership i have a lot of a
secret over there to show you
just click on the join button or there's
a link below
alright so now we have this i'm going to
change this into the green color so it's
easier for you to see
now we need to creating another cross
section i simply going to
use the same trick gonna using the
square
and snapping into this end point coming
at it to coming to the front view and
make a square like this
if the square is too big we can change
it later
but let me make sure i'm making a copy
snapping
into this endpoint and we are going to
copy one here and copy one there okay
so with this i need to make sure that
this one
is smaller
and inside of this shape so i might tilt
it just a little bit more
and put it there and this one need to
tilt it a little bit more like this is
to rotate to
the direction i'm going to sweep this
one as well
i'm going to moving in so that way i can
decide where it's going to end it
all right we are going to do the same
thing
let's go ahead to use a sweep one rail
this is a rail this is a cross section
one two three
and make sure that you record a history
then
make sure that they all align
and then we will get something like this
again we can twist this
by tilted this one a little bit so then
it will be like this
if this one doesn't fit into where that
the red one doesn't meet that red one
there so we can move
this down and then we can also moving
this one up a little bit if we want to
to make sure that it intersect and then
we'll have
a better bowling union together so maybe
this one i want them to be
a little bit smaller like that okay
so if that were all right to you we are
going to finish it
by using the cap command once you use
the
cap you lose the history you will no
longer able to edit it to make them look
nicer i might want to fit at the edges
so let's go ahead to
fit it giving this tiny edges on all of
them let's try 0.2
millimeter and i select all of them
so that will ensure your rendering will
look nicer over there
and next things we wanted to do is we
want to put the jump ring on the top so
we are going to
use taurus and that's making a jump ring
roughly about this size
and having this embed inside of it
on the side we also want to make a bell
so we are coming into the right view and
i want to draw a
oval let's rebuild this oval
into eight point and degree
three so then i wanted to do is one
you want to enlarge this one and moving
this point coming down
so it's not as pointed so get something
like this
we just need to creating a profile i
would like to use the
colony corner starting with the center
snapping
right here and the size probably need to
be smaller so i can fit into the jump
ring
let's see about this size
all right and i want to move it this
down a little bit
there the same thing is going to copy to
the top
roughly about this size and just make
them
wider maybe a little bit thicker
something like this so next that's going
to use the sweep one rail this is a rail
cross section here and here
and make sure that we want to close the
sweep we also want to record a history
so we can change them if we want to
all right if the bell look the right
size to you let's move it down
if not you can always uh have a history
recorded maybe you want this going
bigger
a little bit or wider or
whatever you would like to change for
your belt once you like it bring it down
there
the final things we wanted to do is
adding a stone there
so this will be your heart pendant if
you want to know more about the stone
setting i have the whole
course about it or there's a playlist
for stone setting to watch
i hope you enjoy the video thank you for
watching
see you next
[Music]
foreign